from the first moment that we learned of
the existence of a whistleblower around
the Trump Ukraine phone call corruption
bribery Fiasco I told you on day one
Donald Trump or people around him will
figure out who the whistleblower is and
if they do they will figure out a way to
leak the name of the whistleblower
putting them in obvious and immediate
danger and now we've learned that
they've done it there's a guy who now
works for horrible extremists extremely
depraved Republican congressman Devin
Nunez who previously worked as an
adviser to Donald Trump who leaked
documents that identified the
whistleblowers name the aides name is
Derrick Harvey he gave notes to house
Republicans outing the whistleblower the
goal of course being get the name in the
record of the proceedings in the House
Intelligence Committee because Adam
Schiff said that eventually those
records would be made public as part of
a report on the Trump impeachment
inquiry we've also learned from the
Washington Post that Republicans have
been using the whistleblowers alleged
name multiple times during these private
depositions meaning it is working and it
is working because they do not care that
it puts this whistleblowers life at risk
Mark Zaid is the attorney for the
whistleblower and Mark Zaid says that
his clients life is at risk if his name
gets out that the lives of the
whistleblowers family are at risk if
their name gets out or if the name of
the whistleblower gets out saying quote
exposing the identity of the
whistleblower and attacking our client
would do nothing to undercut the
validity of the complaints allegations
what it would do however is put that
individual and their family at risk of
harm perhaps more important it would
deter future whistleblowers from coming
forward in subsequent administration's
democratic or republican well yeah
that's the point stop future
whistleblowers put this whistleblowers
life at risk in order to ruin their life
and this has led to some far-right news
outlets like
oann one american news network and the
Gateway pundit to start publishing
that they claim is the name of the
whistleblower notice that I'm not saying
what that name is so understand the sick
nature of this the claims of the
whistleblower have already been
corroborated even by people in the Trump
administration wittingly or unwittingly
if you ask them they might not agree
they've corroborated the claims but
they've corroborated the claims they put
out this phone call transcript which is
not a transcript but it's that you know
they call it a summary it's really just
a couple of excerpts of the transcript
and it is already damning to Trump with
ellipses and and redactions it's still
extraordinarily damning to Trump further
incriminating Donald Trump in this
entire fiasco Donald Trump panics and
starts tweeting all sorts of ridiculous
things but then they still want to ruin
the whistleblowers life because this is
just how they operate tell me that what
Derrick Harvey did feeding a name to
Republicans in this way is a
prosecutable offense I don't know if it
is I've got a couple of emails out to
attorney friends this is sort of out of
their area of expertise they're looking
for an answer for me I don't know the
answer is it a prosecutable offense what
Derrick Harvey has done if you have a
sense of that let me know isn't this
closer to the treason that the Wright
claims the whistleblower has done than
anything the whistleblower has actually
done aren't we supposed to be protecting
whistleblowers isn't that one of those
things that is supposed to cross party
lines to the extent that we still cross
party lines in American politics and we
are supposed to protect whistleblowers I
guess not
the president isn't even doing it is
this obstruction is this witness
intimidation in a sense aren't we
supposedly about the rule of law under
the Trump administration the answer is
no that stuff only matters when it's
convenient when it's not it all goes out
the window and further I know I've
mentioned this before but just to give
you the full scope of this there is a
double standard in American politics
when it comes to whistleblowers and
leakers and the left is guilty of this
as well although right now we're talking
about the right putting the
whistleblowers life at stake life at
risk which is something different
altogether but we see this in American
politics a lot there's a whistleblower
or a leak or
whatever and some information goes
public if your side likes the content
that has gone public you ignore how we
got it and you focus only on the content
if your side doesn't like the content
you ignore the implications of the
content and focus only on the fact that
there is a whistleblower that it was
leaked that information in some cases
was stolen or whatever the case may be
this is a status quo in American
politics that being said Republicans are
going away further Republicans are
actually working to put the
whistleblowers life at risk and the
lives of the whistleblowers family at
risk I'm not going to participate in
that I'm not naming the whistleblower
eventually we may know who the person is
and it may simply become part of the
record and at that point okay we will
revisit but for now I'm not going to
participate in this make sure you're
following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show we've got
some great stuff going on there and make
sure you follow me on Instagram as well
don't forget about me guys David Pakman
on Instagram we'll be back right after
this let's go now to part two of our
study of how the trumpian FoxNews
propaganda cycles work this next story
is a story that in a normal world on a
normal planet would not be a story but
in the story of Donald Trump's 2019
reality this is a very real story Fox &
Friends has been caught editing out and
minimizing the booing and the chanting
of lock him up that took place during
Donald Trump's brief appearance at Game
five of the World Series over the
weekend so to remind you yesterday I
played for you a bunch of clips of Trump
showing up in Washington DC for Game
five of the World Series and the entire
place booing him as soon as he appeared
on screen chanting lock him up and Trump
visibly grimacing when he realized that
that's what taking that's what's taking
place the real world is not the echo
chamber filter bubble of his carefully
curated rallies that he's been doing we
talked about that yesterday here is Fox
and Friends yesterday with the booing
notably missing I'm going to do audio
only
because there is footage in this video
of the of copy written content Major
League Baseball is extraordinarily
aggressive so I'm just gonna be doing
audio here let's take a very quick
listen to this because the President and
First Lady were at the game last night
they got there right around the time
that it started and they stayed a pretty
long time they were greeted with Miss
mixed reaction but they were out there
smiling waving to everybody as you can
see in the crowd so that's what happened
right around game time let's take it to
the top of the second inning right now
and show you some of that action
Alvarez hits a two-run home run that yes
so then they just get into highlights
from the game it was all great fun and I
love how she calls it mixed reaction
which might be true only in the most
technical sense but this was a crowd
that was very hostile to the President
of the United States they did not want
Donald Trump there that is the sort of
bigger truth that Fox and Friends can't
or won't tell their audience reminder
this is what was going on yesterday
[Music]
and then of course the chance of lock
him up breakout here's another part of
the stadium also chanting lock him up
[Applause]
so this is not in and of itself the most
important story but it's a really
important story to understand the
propaganda cycle this is the
continuation of the propaganda cycle
Trump goes to the game nobody wants him
there they boo him they chant lock him
up and from clearly notices I mean it's
obvious that he notices then people say
booing I don't know I saw the video this
morning on Fox & Friends
I didn't see any booing anyone saying
that there was booing must be spreading
fake news what terrible people Donald
Trump is right about all the problems
with fake news out there and meanwhile
you have Fox and Friends cutting out the
booing calling it mixed reaction Trump
astana on the internet say it was
liberals who digitally added the booing
that wasn't really there and the cycle
just continues and perpetuates itself
people were joking when this happened
that this is exactly the way it would go
and it went exactly this way Fox cuts
out the booing and calls it mixed
reaction while Trump is spread
conspiracy theories that the booing was
digitally inserted by evil fake news
liberals how stupid does Fox News think
that their audience actually may be that
maybe that's not the right question to
be asking in any case we have a problem
here the self-perpetuating propaganda
cycle I realized I was going in a
direction that maybe is not the right
direction to go in
we need to understand it but we also
need some way of fighting it and
unfortunately the symbiotic relationship
between Donald Trump's talking points
and the unflinching followers that
believe anything he says as if it were
gospel combined with Fox News and the
right-wing media that helped to foment
and expand and signal boost these lies
and disgusting depraved talking points
makes it really difficult to fight
against this stuff and this is one of
the things that is being pointed out by
people who were following Watergate when
it was going on and are following what
is going on right now that is one of the
primary differences between Nixon and
the 70s and Trump right now which is
that they both seem to have done
impeachable things they both are
tampering with witnesses they both are
doing all of the same stuff but Nixon
didn't have something like Fox News and
the right-wing media cycle and circus
which Donald Trump has to his benefit
and that may ultimately be the
difference-maker in preventing public
opinion from completely turning against
Donald Trump we will see make sure
you're following the David Pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show and
follow me on instagram at david pakman I
love this next one this is just a good
old fashioned political dressing down
now in general it's really common that
when presidents go to sporting events
it's sort of a smattering of cheers and
boos and very frequently there are boos
no matter who the president is no matter
what their approval rating happens to be
at the time and part of that is there's
a lot of people who just want to see
sports they don't want presidents there
at all
they don't want it made political in any
sense and that's a common thing that
takes place at sporting events Donald
Trump over the weekend went to the fifth
game of the Major League Baseball World
Series played in Washington DC and he
was not only met with resounding boos
but also chance of lock him up Donald
Trump showed up with a whole cast of
characters and criminals including
Senator Lindsey Graham that totally
disgusting congressman Kevin McCarthy
vile Republican Matt gates and a whole
bunch of others and there was a lot a
lot a lot of booing take a look
[Music]
and then the chance of lock him up
breakout here's another recording of the
lock him up chance and it is just it's
it's like a beautiful symphony on a
chilly fall morning in Boston as you
observe the foliage just hearing this
[Applause]
it's also hilarious that Donald Trump
was asked to and declined to toss out
the first pitch I think we know why
Donald Trump can't throw it would have
been an incredible embarrassment to his
supposed alpha male status if he went
out there and threw out a first pitch
instead chef Jose Andres threw out the
first pitch and he is a big big critic
of Donald Trump and it was funny to see
him do that as well now genuine question
here
Baron Trump is 13 years old today I mean
it's not his birthday today as of today
he's 13 years old I have no idea if
Baron Trump likes baseball but you see
your dad take Lindsey Graham to the
World Series instead of you that seems a
little odd to me I don't know what's
going on there one of the notable things
is that Donald Trump actually looks
visibly shocked that he's being booed by
the entire stadium and this gets to
something I've been wanting to talk
about for a while Donald Trump truly
seems to believe that the echo chamber
in which he lives of Twitter blocking
anybody he doesn't like golf courses
where everybody is just you know
brown-nosing rallies with hand-picked
sycophants he seems to really believe
that's America he seems to think that is
the the mood of the country and that's
why he believes any poll that shows he
has a 55 or 60 percent disapproval
rating must be fake news suddenly he
shows up in front of a crowd that was
not hand-picked for him and it's a
veritable disaster you can visibly see
when Donald Trump realized that the boos
and the chance of lock him up are for
him and he tightens up and he becomes
like a different person
now there's another funny thing about
this the anti Obama right throughout
Barack Obama's presidency thought that
everybody felt like that crowd about
Barack Obama they thought everybody
hates this guy Obama left office with a
59% approval on the last day in office
an approval rating Donald Trump has not
even come close to having at any point
during the nearly three years that he's
been in office Trump literally cannot go
out in public if it's actual public not
one of these curated audience at a rally
you can't go out in public without being
despised and booed I saw funny comment
online it was something like hey listen
some people were booing and some people
were cheering what'd you think of Donald
Trump determines whether you heard the
cheers or the boos this sort of it's all
equal it's all perception that's all it
is very postmodern by the way of some
defenders of Trump
that's not how sound works some people
were cheering you can't hear them over
many of those boos this is like that
Simpsons episode I haven't watched The
Simpsons and so long but some episodes
really made an impression on me there's
an episode where mr. burns kind of like
the you know old rich conservative white
dude equivalent he's getting booed
somewhere in public and he asks are they
booing me no no no sir they're saying
burns burns they're cheering for you mr.
burns very good thank you
here it is one more time there are
military service members on the big
screen people are cheering for them the
second the screen flips the Trump the
booing explodes
[Applause]
quite a day really truly delightful ah
why does he even do that my biggest
complaint about all of this is come on
you're supposedly the alpha male throw
out that first pitch I would love to see
that there have been bad first pitches
and people have survived Gary Dell'Abate
Howard Stern's producer he had a doozy
where I think he hit an umpire in the
back of the head about 30 feet off
center off the center line just pitch
that first pitch I would Bush did it
Obama did it John Kerry was even
photographed throwing footballs or
catching footballs just do it Donald
Trump I would love to see it a
delightful event fun for the entire
family
so House Democrats yesterday as we
discussed they were about to do release
the resolution to formalize the
impeachment inquiry into Donald Trump so
understand that so far they've been pre
interviewing witnesses in private in
accordance with the law by the way as I
will shortly remind you in the next
segment a very interesting segment
upcoming this is now an impeachment
inquiry resolution the house is expected
to vote on it Thursday and it outlines
the process that is going to be taking
place to inquire about whether Donald
Trump should be impeached by the House
of Representatives ultimately
subsequently to be voted on by the
Senate what does the resolution say well
for starters at its conclusion if the
inquiry is going to create a public
report of their findings and this is
important in the sense that it is one of
the areas that has been heavily
criticized by Republicans that
everything is happening quote in secret
well in reality nothing has actually
happened yet there's just been pre
interviewing of witnesses but at the
conclusion of this inquiry there will be
a public report that is going to be
issued now importantly to Donald Trump
who as you may know has been complaining
about there's no due process I'm not
getting any due process here even though
we simply didn't get to that point yet
nothing wrong has happened so far the
resolution
outlines the due process that Donald
Trump is going to get and you can make
the argument that it's actually
generous to Donald Trump the resolution
outlines some new due process rights for
the President of the United States
overall in a sort of balanced sober
rational analysis there's really nothing
controversial in the resolution
whatsoever it's very similar to the
process that was employed during Bill
Clinton's impeachment back in 1998 the
difference being that with Bill Clinton
there was this Independent Counsel
report remember this guy Ken Starr who
was brought in to investigate Bill
Clinton there was a report which came
which present was presented to the House
committees involved by the Independent
Counsel specifically through the
Judiciary Committee this time it's a
little bit different the house itself
will be doing the investigating and it
will be the entity the Judiciary
Committee will be the entity issuing the
full report rather than receiving it
from a special prosecutor independent
prosecutor so now the rubber is sort of
going to start meeting the road and what
I mean by that is we're going to see
very quickly if Republicans and Donald
Trump settle down over there are no
guidelines and no due process because
the resolution gives them everything
that they've been asking for now of
course there's a chance call me a
skeptic call me a cynic there's a chance
that it wasn't really about process and
guidelines all along it was just
something that Republicans and Trump
grasped onto like a last desperate straw
to try to stop what it is that is going
on but in any case if we go by what
they've said Republicans have been
asking for their own subpoena power to
bring in witnesses they are being given
that by this resolution Donald Trump has
been asking or demanding or complaining
about not having due process
he is getting that we have very clear
guidelines here for what this process is
going to look like and what the
deliverable is going to be deliverable
by the way doesn't have to be a bad word
although when Donald Trump uses it it
often alludes to corruption the
deliverable in this case will be a
report a public report summarizing the
impeachment inquiry Trump wanted due
process and the route resolution gives
him that and it's really important to
remember that the resolution also by the
way outlines and this is where it starts
the
get very interesting the resolution
outlines the possibility of public
hearings which would be just endlessly
fascinating Congressman Jim McGovern
who's Democrat from Massachusetts
chairman of the Rules Committee he
released the resolution yesterday
afternoon I actually bumped into Jim
McGovern over the weekend in Northampton
Massachusetts at the world-famous
Haymarket cafe very exciting moment for
me he clearly forgot who I was and had
no recollection of having met me but
regardless Jim McGovern releasing for us
yesterday the resolution so prepare
yourselves now for just a new wave of
bad faith arguments from Republicans
about how this is still unfair how it's
still a witch-hunt how it is still a
terrible unfair example of presidential
harassment and also expect the White
House to again start moving the bar to
come up with new excuses for why they
are going to be ignoring and directing
everyone under their purview to ignore
all subpoenas because before it was
there's no guidelines there's no due
process it's an open-ended secret thing
that's going on now we've been told here
are the guidelines here is the due
process and there will be a public
report after possibly public hearings
they will come up with something new to
justify in their minds and in the minds
of their supporters why they are going
to not cooperate with this inquiry what
I am most looking forward to is that in
the resolution this is just great it
mentions 45 minutes of uninterrupted
questioning of witnesses by each side
Democrats would get 45 minutes and then
Republicans would get 45 minutes with
witnesses in public testimony if you've
watched congressional testimony before
you probably remember that before there
is even a prelude and one question asked
they're low on time because often times
each member of the House will get five
minutes it's just not enough time still
sometimes there are fireworks but it is
not enough time forty-five minutes of
uninterrupted questioning of a single
witness the fireworks and the implosions
that we could see in 45 minutes of
straight
Jenning could be absolutely glorious and
I am very very much looking forward to
it and this may be it maybe in the end
Republicans shooting themselves in the
foot by demanding transparency because
now they have it and it doesn't look
like it's the type of transparency that
is going to be particularly good for the
narrative that they have been crafting
more upcoming on this I am sure I want
to hear from you how do you think the
vote will go in the house well the most
straightforward prediction is just a
party line a straight party line vote
and what do you expect if and when these
public impeachment inquiry hearings
actually get going
so it is now being alleged and it seems
pretty damn clear that Donald Trump's
big powerful squinting at the camera
strong-looking Situation Room photo that
was supposedly taken while the raid that
led to the suicide of Isis leader Abu
Bakr al-baghdadi was happening was a
staged photograph likely taken hours
after the event and that Donald Trump
was actually playing golf when the raid
took place I already told you that
Donald Trump admits to having told the
Russians but not House leadership about
the attack in advance I also already
discussed how that puts our national
security at risk it puts our sovereignty
at risk we don't need to go back to that
we did that already let's just talk
about the picture briefly my BS detector
was going crazy as soon as I saw this
picture it seemed so obvious that this
was another element of Trump trying to
recreate Barack Obama's Osama bin Laden
moment with the picture from the
Situation Room with the speech that he
gave and with all of it the picture
looks completely staged to anyone with
common sense everyone looks like they're
posing it was posted by dance Covino
scavino as an assistant to trump and
director of social media and of course
the trumpets ate this up like it was
being spoon-fed to them but then it very
quickly started getting weird Pete Souza
who's a photographer he's been a
photographer for numerous presidents
ending with Barack Obama
notice that the raid took place at 3:30
p.m. Eastern Time Washington DC time and
the IPTC data on this photo
says that the picture was taken at 1705
that's 505 p.m. about 90 minutes 95
minutes after the raid took place now
put that aside for a second just looking
at the picture suggests that it's staged
you see everyone clearly posed the
picture is symmetrical it looks it one
of the pictures looks like it's being
taken in a way that would actually block
the view of everyone in the room of what
it is that they are supposedly they're
observing it looks like a setup
there's the now-infamous picture of
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton and Joe
Biden taken during the raid that killed
Osama bin Laden and it actually looks
like a real candid picture with people
reacting in real-time to what's going on
rather than a staged photo op 90 minutes
after the incident is over now it's
possible and it's been discussed that
was the raid still going on more than 90
minutes later but the idea that they'd
be in that pose after 90 minutes late 90
minutes after the raid ended is strange
to say the least but then we get more
information it is now believed that
Donald Trump was golfing at 333 p.m.
Washington DC time the raid was at 3:30
Trump golfing at 333 how was he in the
Situation Room watching this live there
are reports that Donald Trump's
motorcade started coming back to the
White House after 4:15 p.m. Eastern Time
once again suggesting the Situation Room
picture had to have been staged long
after the fact now in reality this
shouldn't matter because there are so
many things that really do matter a lot
here why did Donald Trump tell Russians
before congressional leadership about
this raid was this operation legal
always a question when US military
operations are happening in other
countries does taking out one person in
Isis even really matter in the fight
against Isis since it is cell based and
decentralized and more ideological than
about individual leaders does this
really undo the damage that Trump did in
the region by pulling troops from
northern Syria instantly endangering the
Kurds there are real issues to talk
about but understand
num we've become to Donald Trump's
character that a totally staged
situation room photo is released we
found out that he was actually playing
golf at the time and were completely
desensitized to it I've said before the
further Trump is from making decisions
it's better in a sense we should be glad
that Trump was nowhere near the
Situation Room when this raid was
happening his presence could only have
worsened the possible outcomes if he
wasn't golfing he might have been
tweeting about it as it was happening
right I mean it's really not good for
Trump to be near these things but this
is just not somebody who's in it to help
the country this is not someone who's
here to better circumstances for as many
Americans as possible or to be a
participant in this thing we know as
humanity on planet Earth for the
betterment of as many people as possible
he's in it for himself
golfing self-enrichment staging a
picture that he thinks makes him look
look good even though the picture is
obviously staged it's sick and
geopolitically the most serious thing
and I mentioned this but it's it's
really where the focus of our
conversation should be killing leaders
of terrorist groups doesn't do that much
in 2019 there is an environment and a
geopolitical status quo that foments the
ideologies that lead to things like Isis
that's what you need to change if you
kill a leader or you show up and you get
a leader to kill themselves and three of
their kids has happened the number two
is promoted and that's it and lastly as
a reminder for this week of gloating by
Donald Trump that I hope you're ready
for remember what Donald Trump said back
in 2012 Donald Trump tweeted in 2012
stop congratulating Obama for killing
bin Laden the Navy SEALs killed bin
Laden I wonder I wonder if Donald Trump
is going to apply that exact same logic
to what took place here particularly
since he was golfing as this raid was
being carried out and his involvement
could only have put the operation at
risk without helping anything at all let
me know what you think I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman while you're there follow the
show on twitter at david pakman show and
make sure you follow me on twit
because we are back to live streams this
week at twitch.tv slash David Pakman so
the week has turned really bad for
Donald Trump on top of being booed at
the World Series game on top of getting
bad GDP numbers by his own standards
which I'll talk about later
despite the formalization of an
impeachment inquiry against him starting
to move forward in the house despite
being caught staging a Situation Room
picture 90 minutes after the raid that
led to the death of Isis leader Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi had ended there was
devastating testimony given against
Donald Trump by witnesses including
testimony that mentions that there was a
concerted effort to remove references to
Joe Biden and the company buries m'a in
that quote transcript of Trump's July 25
phone call with the Ukrainian president
zalenski we are covering that piece
separately so I'm not going to get into
detail about it now but needless to say
it has thrown Donald Trump into one of
his tizzies this time forcing him to
burp out a series of panicked anti
impeachment rants riddled with
misspellings and all this guy knows he's
in trouble see if you can make heads or
tails out of this Trump tweeting
Republicans are very unified and
energized in our fight on the
impeachment hoax with the do-nothing
Democrats and now are starting to go
after the substance even more than the
very beat then the very in fair process
not unfair the in fair process because
just the casual reading of the
transcript leads everybody to see that
the call with the Ukrainian president
was a totally appropriate one as he said
no pressure
this impeachment nonsense is just a
continuation of the witch-hunt hoax
which has been going on since before I
even got elected Republicans go with
substance and close it out so understand
he's panicking because everything is
happening as it should and it's really
bad for him Nancy Pelosi and Democrats
are formalizing the impeachment inquiry
they're giving him the due process that
he claims to have been denied witnesses
are coming forward and saying what they
say like for example Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander VIN Minh which we'll get to so
when you look at the substance of what
Trump is tweeting it makes no sense the
process is not
fair or in fair as Trump says it's the
same process that took place with Bill
Clinton the transcripts lead everyone to
see the Ukraine call as appropriate he
claims well he you didn't release a
transcript you released some truncated
nonsense and even in and of itself it
was incriminating now it is being
alleged that specific mentions of Joe
Biden were removed from what you
released his continued references to
that summary as a transcript this has
become one of the most frequently
repeated misleading memes about this
entire fiasco that he's made that it's a
witch-hunt I mean he says that about
everything of course that's not true
so let's go back to the basics is this
how an innocent person truly behaves but
as I've been saying for months if you
think that this is Trump starting to
lose it just wait if and until the
public hearings begin it will be a
completely new Donald Trump altogether
the rants the tweets the erratic
behavior the attempts to cover up it's
going to get really really bad and a
little bit later I'll come back to the
testimony from Alexandrov Inman we
received some very interesting news over
the weekend Donald Trump's latest former
national security adviser is in
negotiation to testify in Donald Trump's
impeachment inquiry and if he does this
is testimony that could completely blow
up Donald Trump Boulton to be clear is a
disgusting neocon Warhawk from the era
of george w bush he was regularly at
odds with donald trump during his tenure
as national security adviser but he may
indeed be just a major player in
exposing how bad the corruption is under
donald trump Bolton's lawyers and of
course everyone associated with Donald
Trump seems to end up needing lawyers
even Trump's own lawyers making
attorneys get attorneys the alternate
interpretation for Magha boltons lawyers
say they're talking to the committee's
that are involved in the impeachment
inquiry and that john bolton may indeed
be deposed it is alleged that during
Bolton's time as national security
adviser he would regularly criticize
Rudy Giuliani for Rudy's efforts to dig
up dirt on Biden and
he would call them drug deals he would
call what Rudy Guiliani was doing drug
deals he would encourage staffers at the
National at the NSA to report this stuff
to administration lawyers it's unclear
if those reports ever actually took
place so far it's been mostly not very
well known diplomats who have been
testifying as part of this impeachment
inquiry but this would very quickly
change if John Bolton were to testify
and it is really important to remember
that truly horrible people like John
Bolton can be useful in a fight against
Donald Trump's corruption and self in
Richmond and peddling influence for his
own benefit Bolton is disgusting I mean
this this was one of the architects of
the Iraq war Bolton represents the worst
of the neoconservative impulses of the
last several decades of American foreign
policy but listen if he's useful then
have him testify why not there are
people hoping that this will be an open
door testimony but it wouldn't be that
part of this is actually about
preventing witnesses from coordinating
their stories and if these testimonies
were in open republic you could have a
witness come in and say something and
then you could have other witnesses hear
that and then go in and tell the same or
a very similar story to make it seem as
though everything is on the up-and-up so
that's not the way that it's going to
happen the really interesting thing here
is that the instincts that are natural
to john bolton for which we are
disgusted by him right I mean his
bloodthirsty take-no-prisoners
reactionary nature that may be what
ultimately leads him to show up and to
take down Donald Trump Boulton in the
end is total pond scum I mean the guise
of complete bloodthirsty bottom feeder
but he will do what he sees as patriotic
and it just might be like we might just
happen to overlap in that he will see
denouncing and exposing what Donald
Trump has done as the patriotic thing to
do his values are counter to most of our
values in my audience would be my
but they might overlap in that we all
think Donald Trump should be held
accountable we all think hopefully of
john bolton does we all believe that
there should be consequences to actions
taken by presidents of the united states
and in fact it actually sort of
stunningly shows us how bad things have
gotten that in the trump
administration's current and former
staffers someone is antithetical to my
values and to what I believe are
American values as John Bolton might end
up being a sort of de facto good guy and
I use that term I mean it's like painful
to use it about Bolton but he may end up
serving the role of a good guy in this
particular very narrow set of
circumstances by showing up and just
telling the truth about what he saw and
to be clear he's not a good guy he may
play one in this fiasco involving the
Donald Trump administration
of course I'll keep you posted on the
latest news about John Bolton's
testimony
we also are that there's a bigger list
of people again listen I mean we've been
talking about in the end if Democrats
don't enforce subpoenas this is all just
BS that that's the reality there are
higher level people that have been had
documents subpoenaed and who may be
subpoenaed personally to testify we'll
get into it if and when it looks like
they actually might otherwise the story
I'm going to have to keep telling you is
that spineless Democrats refuse to
actually attempt to enforce the
subpoenas now every time I say that
people email me and say David come on
you know it is not ultimately up to
Democrats whether the subpoenas are
enforced Trump controls this that and
the other thing and are you really gonna
see the sergeant-at-arms of the house go
and hold people in contempt I'm not
there yet
all I'm saying is let's at least see
Democrats try to enforce the subpoenas
and then if they try and our stonewalled
then we'll deal with that we'll cross
that bridge when we come to it but a
priori saying it doesn't matter if
Democrats try to enforce them because
it's not gonna be you know it's not
going to Nancy Pelosi personally going
and slapping the cuffs on anyone what
depends is whether the systems in place
will do it
let's see the Democrats try first and
then see how far we get